welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and I have
watched Avengers endgame an insane
amount of times whether it's the way it
closes out the saga or just the nice
little callbacks in the movie something
keeps bringing you back I'm currently in
the middle of making a big watching
order video for all of the Marvel
properties and over the last eight
months have watched everything that
falls into the umbrella
whether it's agent Carter agents of
shield cloak-and-dagger daredevil or the
movies themselves chances are you name
it I watched it with all of this info
stuffed in my head I've noticed some
crazy details in Avengers endgame and
throughout this video I'm gonna be
breaking down some of the best things
that most people have missed there will
be heavy spoilers here so if you haven't
had a chance to watch your vengeance and
game and don't want to Who am I kidding
you've seen the movie make sure you
subscribe to the channel for videos like
this every day now let's get into our
breakdown of insane details you missed
in the ventures endgame okay so one of
the best things about infinity war and
endgame as a whole is that the latter
pays off so many minor things in the
former that the Russo brothers should be
applauded for their sheer amount of
attention to detail both movies were
filmed back-to-back but even so there
are still some tiny little
self-referential things that not only
show character development but also add
to the world-building when talking to
dr. strange Tony Stark and Wong Bruce
Banner is surprised to learn that Ben
and Jerry's have named an ice cream
flavor after him this gets a big follow
up an end game when we can see Hulk
eating it during the planning stages of
the time heist I don't know why Ben and
Jerry still haven't made Hulka Hulka
burning fudge yet but yeah I want that
more than anything right now also an
infinity war
Tony uses a nanotech shield to cover
himself from an attack right Thanos this
severely depletes his supply of the
microscopic machines and leads to him
being almost killed by the mad Titan in
order to make sure this doesn't happen
again in endgame stark uses an energy
shield as protection which won't drain
on his armor clearly he's learned from
his mistakes and he's not the only one
either at the start of infinity war
after Thanos manages to get his hands on
two Infinity stones he removes his armor
believing he is now invincible however
at the end of the movie the character is
almost killed by Thor and thus when he
makes his attack at the end of endgame
the younger version of him realizes that
it's probably sensible to keep the armor
on every time Thor attacks the villain
in the film he goes for the head this
was of course set up in Avengers
infinity war when due to his need to
gloat
he went for the chest rather than the
killing blow because of this Thanos was
able to wipe out half of all life within
the galaxy and then retreat to the
garden in endgame he's here to kill him
properly this time and from their first
meeting all the way until the final
battle every time Thal clashes with the
character he aims directly for his head
during this fight we watched the awesome
moment in which Captain America lifts
Mounier and gains the power of Thor as
Stannis cannot lift the item himself he
instead grabs caps wrists rather than
the hammer itself when fighting Thanos
cap throws his shield and then the
hammer at it which knocks Thanos off
balance in is a callback to when the two
struck one another and avenges caps arm
has scales on it and you can actually
see these under the upper layer of his
outfit in infinity war these scales
first made an appearance in black
panther and could show that after
dropping Bucky off in Wakanda
sure he gave him some upgrades earlier
in the film the Hulk Buster grabs Thanos
you can see that the left arm on the
armor isn't painted this is because it
was detached during the final battle in
the prior movie Thanos also breaks cap
shield
similar to the way that it was destroyed
in Tony Stark's vision all the way back
in age of Ultron infinity war was all
about making sacrifices in order to win
Doctor Strange save Tony in exchange for
handing over the time stone and there
were several more examples of this in
the film I know this was part of his
grand plan but still it shows that they
put the few before that many
cap famously said that they don't trade
lives when vision offered up his life in
order to destroy the mine stone and this
showed that they wouldn't make the hard
play thus danus was able to collect all
of the Infinity stones and win this is
because he was willing to sacrifice
Aurra in contrast the Avengers win an
endgame because they do make sacrifices
including the death of Black Widow and
of course Tony Stark thematically it's
amazing and really pays off what was set
up in the prior film there are also
hints an infinity war that Gomorrah
wasn't the first person to be sacrificed
for the soulstone as she lays there dead
at the bottom of the ravine we can see a
pool of blood beside her
could this be Natasha's from 2014 well
we do know that she did trade her life
for the stone and then cap returned it
so therefore this moment would be
permanent and it wouldn't cause a branch
timeline when the Tasha tells Steve that
she has to work on fixing everything the
soundtrack is also a variation on the
soul stone sacrifice music which
foreshadows her death later when Steve
sets out on his mission to return the
stones he says to Bucky don't do
anything stupid until I get back Bucky
replies how can I you're taking all the
stupid with you this is actually a
callback to Captain America the First
Avenger in which the conversation was
reversed with Steve delivering the
opposite dialogue to Bucky before he
went off to fight in World War 2 before
leaving his mission cap looks in the
direction of where his old version would
like to be sat and says I'll be back at
the end of the film Steve and Peggy
finally get that dance and it's the same
song from when Steve found fury in his
apartment in Winter Soldier the song is
called it's been a long long time which
is of course a reference to the journey
that Steve has been on to finally get to
his long-lost love when taking the Pym
particles from Hank he takes four in
total this is two for him in stock to
return to the present and one for him to
go to the Past and another to eventually
returned back to this timeline after
returning from the past on his own
little journey
Hawkeye seems pretty beat Scott grabbed
some orange slices which is a nice
little callback to civil war in which he
asked if anyone had any to help ease his
pain Natasha makes a peanut butter jelly
sandwich which Scott shows up and eats
she cuts it diagonally which is a
callback to Nick Fury telling Carol that
he can't eat toast that's been cut in
the same way could she be in a habit of
doing this to stop Nick from stealing a
lunch at work well we'd like to think so
that's not the only neat little Easter
Egg that ties into other movies in the
MCU in Thor Ragnarok
for olden days he say stat Thor and his
brother remember this place home this
scene takes place in Norway and is
actually the location that knew as God
would come to be an endgame but it's not
the only time the area makes a big
appearance tones berg has been a crucial
location in the MCU right from the
beginning this is the location where the
Asgardians fought centuries ago and it's
also where the tesseract was hidden and
then taken by Red Skull it is of course
where Odin dies and when you as God
comes to be so yeah lots of things are
tied to this exact spot
cheering Ragnarok a line is also set up
and paid off in endgame loki tells thor
that he cannot see into the future as
he's not a witch an endgame Frigga can
tell that thor is from the future
because as she says she was raised by
witches it's not the only touching
exchange between parent and child that
has major callbacks in the MCU either
and in endgame when Howard asks Tony
about his father Stark Jr says he did
his best this is a nod to the Baths
demonstration in civil war in which Tony
says that he wishes he could have told
his father I love you dad and I know he
did the best he could
I'm not crying you're crying during this
scene Jarvis from aging Carter pops up
as well I know you've probably heard
that 100 times but yeah I just wanted to
add it in
there's tons of callbacks to and loads
of nice little Easter eggs in the scene
in which Tony and Scott go to stark
tower in 2012 Tony's armor retracts from
the feet first to silence its landing
and make it so they aren't heard
entering the room Thor says that they're
going for lunch which is a reference to
the SH warmer seen from the post-credits
scene of Avengers Tony also flicks
ant-man with insane accuracy because
he'd been practicing playing paper
football with nebula for weeks when
exiting the building
Tony replays a similar move to which he
did in the first Avengers movie however
his suit quickly engages over him
instead of when he almost hits the
pavement which shows how far as
technology has come since 2012 speaking
of Technology the quantum suits
themselves also show the melding of a
lot of tech in the MCU they use Pym tech
in order to shrink the nanotech is from
Iron Man and wakanda's nano machines and
the visor is from the Guardians and
ratchet sir oh sorry I mean rocket
speaking of ratchet
calls him this in the film and it's a
reference to the very Sony character who
is also great with machines the Russos
love casting people they know and
Anthony Russo's daughter plays Hawkeye's
in the film this is who we see training
in the beginning and you may notice
sounds of birds and wildlife in the
background after the snap is carried out
these disappear showing that a lot of
animals were also killed when Thanos
made the devastating move the child we
seen Captain America the Winter Soldier
also returns to take a picture with
smart Hulk at the diner two community
actors pop up including the vet Nicole
Brown who gets in a lift with Steve and
Tony and also Ken Jong who is a guard at
the lock up ji-yong is reading a book
called terminal breech which is about a
president who decides to destroy
countless nuclear weapons at the cost of
millions of lives this of course has
ties to Thanos his plan in which he
killed trillions in order to save the
galaxy spider-man told Tony and civil
war that he'd never get a chance to play
football due to his powers but we see
him get the opportunity in the final
battle in which the character literally
runs the gauntlet in spider-man
homecoming there's a hilarious scene in
which Peter thought Tony was going for a
hug and Tony says we're not there yet
but in endgame Tony and Peter hug which
shows how far their friendship has come
Tony Stark is able to solve the
time-travel model after seeing a picture
of him and Peter holding an inverted
diploma this inspires him to invert the
mobius strip which as we know is crucial
in allowing the group to go back you can
also see Peter's traditional spider-man
costume under the suit when it becomes
damaged this is because he had it on
under the iron spider armor all the way
back in infinity war as he died on Titan
and then came straight to the final
battle after being resurrected he
wouldn't have had time to change when
war machine is stuck in Avengers HQ he
gets out the suit by saying canopy
canopy canopy this is code for eject
eject eject in the air force the pilot
says this to their back sea air so that
they can leave first you can also see
the Iron patriot Mach 2 armor in the
background of the scene which makes an
appearance later on the wasp leaves a
tiny small portal and we also see
spider-man swinging on ant-man in order
to move forward the end of the film
culminates with Tony carrying out the
snap and killing Danice in his forces
not only can you hear Tony's nano
taking the stones off Dennis's gauntlet
and putting them into his suit but it's
also a couple of neat little callbacks
to the prior film the first time we here
at Donald's talkin infinity war he says
he knows what it's like to lose and how
it turns the legs to jelly when dying
the first thing he does is sit down why
this scene is also perfect is because
the camera movement mimics his victory
at the end of Avengers infinity war it
pans across exactly the same way and
shows the victory and defeat in a
similar light at tony's funeral everyone
stands still except for mantis who sways
in a rocking motion this was put in
place because it's typical of mantids to
sway when stood still Morgan tells happy
that she wants some cheeseburgers and
this is a reference to the first Ironman
in which Tony made happy get him some
after returning home from being held
hostage the credits end with the
clanging noise of Ironman building his
suit in the first film and this brings
everything full circle all 22 films
which is also paid lip-service to buy
stop in the beginning of endgame who
says they've been adrift for 21 days no
22 and that's our entire list I had a
blast making this video and hope you had
fun watching it obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on the tidbits so
comment below and let me know make sure
you subscribe to the channel for videos
like this every day and if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out our breakdown of every
time the penny wise was hidden in the
background of a scene in it chapter one
and two that's gonna be linked at the
end and every month on the 15th we give
away free blu-rays and all you have to
do to be in with a chance of winning dr.
sleep is leave a comment and subscribe
with notifications on you want to
support the channel and get to see
content early then please consider
clicking the join button you can also
come chat to us on our discord link
below or a definition whitey on Twitter
thanks for sticking to the end
I've been definition you've been the
best now see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]